we have a warm bin so Hyundai has this
new hybrid vehicle called the ionic and
they've challenged us to live
sustainably for a week we are going to
be living in a future house what does
the future look like for you we're not a
baby right yes different video so we're
not just going that 0 we're going that
positive 0 basically just means that
your footprint whether its carbon or
water energy food is not having a
negative impact I feel like I'm a pretty
wasteful person i order a lot of stuff
online and it probably comes from far
far away it always comes in cardboard
boxes I like eating red meat even though
I know it like uses a lot of water I
take a really long showers I take really
long showers I mean I recycle I'm not a
monster
we actually need to do more and you can
do more growing your own food locally
making your own energy even making your
own water if you made 2 watts and you
use one one you'd be giving one watt
back we are going to try and make more
energy than we take the electric company
is gonna pay us I thought we were just
gonna have to be Net Zero no no wait
that's it Oh
[Music]
feature house open future house open oh
thank you we built this house with the
idea that you actually don't have to
give up anything to have a better
lifestyle that's better for your health
it's better for your wallet and better
for your environment showers are super
super efficient we have a grey water
system you guys probably won't have to
turn on the heat or the cooling because
the house is so well insulated the
kitchen has an induction cooktop you can
cook a lot faster and with less energy
use so this is the future it's day one
in our future house the very first thing
I want to do is like use a bunch of I
want to turn things on turn everything
right there's so many cool things to
play with here's the future mr. farmers
future love you
number one is keep it local you can do
so much with your fork your eating
choices have huge effects look at our
little plant ease sustainable right now
we're so system sustainable I honestly
don't know what I'm doing are you like I
remember this from elementary school you
did this in elementary yeah give it
enough space so it can breathe that yeah
you don't need to like no that's too
much water and energy are critical
there's less than 3% of fresh water on
the planet rain wash harvested in a
1,400 gallon rainwater tank we just
simply throw a lever and water the
plants ah water foods that are better
for the environment and less good for 1
pound of meat it is the equivalent of
2,500 gallons of water you know I I just
I really like eating beef your radishes
taste like oh they're like little onions
[Music]
vinaigrettes it was the lemon lemon
olive oil
doo-doo-doo-doo I've heard a little
salad hmm I don't kind of wish it wasn't
ham sandwich
not bad feature house make me cookies
doesn't work hey Ariel guess what in the
future your lights will play jams it's
coming out of the light what's up what
falling out with no basket and the whole
black gonna see me and get a problem
without no acting we got anxious silly
ass [ __ ] and they calling out put a song
about my cheekbone whip boy and bolt it
in the no it's actually really nice to
wake up with the Sun and this house just
has like an energy to it
I'm diggin it good mmm you're soaking up
the energy this family as far as
recycling leftover table scraps is we
have a worm bin they make their worm tea
and we fertilize our plants with them
now worm tea is a nice name for poop
right yes it's poop let's turn out some
worm poop I was gonna say it smells like
coffee but it doesn't it smells really
bad
oh yeah crazy okay this is worth it now
Ariel is going to put the worm tea on
the plants very carefully no wait oh
hell yeah wait though
how's it yes very nice that's better
it's better worm tea on our lettuce wash
it off yeah
yeah Morty oh you have a graywater
system if you've washed your clothes and
you've used the right kind of soap you
can water our plants in the backyard
with a lever I don't think that this is
right oh it's great water no this is
that grey water this is suds come to
your house
turn up I hope we didn't kill the tree
no no no no no no no no no no no no
today was really hard Ned it has gotten
so frustrated he ordered a pizza what
would David say oh sorry not sorry
oh my goodness what is going on here
though my me I'm just rising with the
Sun I think that in the future me is
what we call biomimetic design as
mimicking nature arms will evolve
organically because nature does it much
better than humans can
apparently this painting behind us was
made with worms so we're gonna try and
mimic nature today by making art with
our worms you dip your worm in the paint
here and then they're gonna wriggle
around it's all non-toxic paint oh I
don't know
ah no guy you ready to get crafty he's
like gonna be a moody artist here you go
he's having fun guys just going for gold
over here do you think we mimic nature
with our art yeah oh look at you like a
special night yeah you look beautiful
hey and our food looks gorgeous as well
really gasps we're keeping it so local
ten feet away to our last night in the
future last night in the future do you
think we did it there were definitely
moments where we were not as successful
working barns were there other moments
where feel like we were doing okay it's
good it's not waste its art okay here's
my showers I want because of science
this wasn't actually that unattainable
yeah small changes small changes so we
lived in a future house for a week it's
amazing there is that technology that we
can be creating energy over the course
of this week especially knowing we don't
have to change our lifestyle we have
abundant resources we're just not using
them as intelligently as we should
mattalast meal yeah open my eyes as to
what a vegetarian diet can do final
verdict let's check out how much energy
we use this week okay oh we did really
just barely had positive 69 kilowatt
hours I don't think that that many
get that money either but technically
positive I am still kind of bummed we
can't talk to the house
okay Google tell blue link to start my
ionic sure a remote start request has
been sent it just needed a woman's touch
from we should probably go ideally we're
just smarter and more efficient in the
future and that doesn't compromise our
quality of life it adds to it
and now we'd like to reveal to you the
world premiere of our worm art actually
I think that's upside down no oh yeah
it's very important